[Music]
[Applause]
spring and steve sands one of the great
voices with nbc sports played by play
host and interviewer and we'll get to
the pj tour in a moment let me get your
thoughts on tom brady the broadcaster
you know what dan i was thinking about
it when you were just talking about it
and we had tiger in the booth david
faraday and i on nbc in december at the
hero world challenge tiger the greatest
player of his generation tom brady the
greatest player of his generation uh and
we were all wondering how's this going
to play out and we had tiger in the
booth dan for probably 40 45 minutes
live golf going on his golf acumen is
incredibly high just like tom brady's
his preparation is
you know unmatched just like tom brady's
and we all thought how's this going to
work out and tiger was fabulous dan he
was incredible talking about the players
of today versus the way he played the
way golf courses are attacked now uh
versus when he was say in his heyday um
he was very in tune with the guys who
were playing the game at the time and
the best players in the world who were
there at the hero world challenge
and he was fantastic we were ready to
sign him up right there uh back in
december and this was five months ago um
i think it's potential uh for tom brady
dan i like you you never know how it's
going to play out you know he's going to
be ready you know he's going to give it
his all you know he's going to work and
he's going to prep
the question is does he have the
enthusiasm
does he have
the ability to go criticize other
players who he's played against coaches
he's played against coaches he's played
for
i think it's going to be fascinating and
why wouldn't you if you have the money
to do it like fox does why wouldn't you
sign tom brady his star power alone is
going to make people watch but when you
have somebody polarizing like tom brady
is not easy to root for for a lot of
people right he's got everything
and now he got he's going to make even
more money
after playing football than he did when
he made you know 300 million dollars
playing football yeah i
i think that
we love to what
make people stars and then tear them
down is that how it works yeah
the the analogy in golf would be with
tiger the only person you could possibly
compare tom brady to in today's game is
tiger and i'm telling you tiger was
fabulous in the booth with us he was
insightful uh he was entertaining he
told some stories uh he said what it's
like to be these guys
he was allowing the audience dan to kind
of get a little bit of an understanding
of what justin thomas and john rom and
these great young players are now going
through and what they're about to go
through if they bust that door wide open
so if you're tom brady and you're on fox
and you're standing next you're sitting
next to kevin in the booth and you're at
a huge game and say it's a cowboy game
and dak prescott hasn't yet won that
super bowl that everybody is dying for
him to win to validate his contract and
validate what everybody thinks is
amazing potential out of dak prescott
i'm just using him as an example dan
tom can tell the audience exactly what
he's about to go through and what he's
trying to do and if he's able to
communicate that and tom by the way like
tiger dan
has become a much better communicator
seems like he's been freed up since he
left new england and went down to tampa
bay um i think that it's worth a shot
from fox um and again he's the biggest
star in all of professional football
maybe in all of sports he's recognizable
by anybody who's never heard of a hockey
puck a basketball or a first down line
and i think i think it's worth a shot uh
to give tom the money if they have the
money yeah which clearly they do and uh
i think it's going to be fascinating to
see what type of communicator he is with
a headset on and not just with a
microphone in his face being asked
questions by people like us steve sands
golf channel nbc sports i wanted to talk
to you about this live tour the saudi
back tour
and what this is going let's say nobody
knows anything about this topic the
casual fan what what would you tell them
about this tour and the impact potential
impact on the pga tour
well to the casual fan i would say if
you've heard of the usfl uh it's not
analogous because one's international uh
for the most part and one was completely
domestic the usfl tried to go against
the nfl years ago they had herschel
walker they had kelvin bryant they had
guys like that uh and it didn't work uh
what liv golf is trying to do is compete
against the pga tour and the pga tour is
the biggest and baddest uh wealthiest
most prestigious uh golf tour in the
world um and they are trying to stave
off uh any type of competition and
that's what liv golf is trying to do
they are backed uh by saudi dollars
and they have a lot of money um someone
told me the other day it's kind of like
playing poker with someone then and
sitting across the table and that guy
has all the chips uh clearly they have
the money and they have the backing uh
whether or not they'll be able to get
the players and be able to get this
thing started to compete
literally compete against the pga tour
we'll have to wait and see but also greg
norman is heading this up and it feels
like greg norman is really really mad at
the pga tour
yeah he's been mad at the pga tour for a
long time if you remember all the way
back i know you're at golfing you and i
text back and forth and know each other
for years uh for the casual sports fan
but for the die hard golf fan they know
this but for the casual sports fan who
who's you know listening and watching
your show right now dan
way back when 25 30 years ago greg
norman who's from australia
huge personality was an incredibly
popular and polarizing figure in golf he
wanted to start a big world tour
the pga tour thwarted that off and they
built what became the world golf
championship events a three or four golf
tournament series that were played
around the world
and one of them is still played today
actually the match play in austin
texas wasn't played in march and
greg has had an interesting relationship
with the pga tour ever since
and and clearly he is now on the live
golf side as opposed to the pga tour
side currently
was phil mickelson suspended was he in
timeout and now he's allowed to play in
the pga championship i don't know if he
was suspended officially um
we were told that the players that he
took a break uh and that the pga tour
accepted that um if he wanted to play
i'm i'm sure that he could go
and take the correct routes uh have the
correct communication with the pga tour
commissioner jay monahan and get back
onto the golf course competing uh at a
pga tour level uh you know phil
as you've documented many times um got
himself in some trouble with some of the
things that he said um and needed to
take a time out and not just a 20 dan he
needed to take a full and he clearly has
taken a full he has not competed in a
long long time pga tour going to be able
to keep these like you're
i'm trying to figure out
what that relationship is like you don't
want to anger these players you still
need these players for your tour
yeah um
can they suspend people
find people like i don't i don't know
what
i don't know what the end game will be
here of how you can keep everybody
happy-ish on the pga tour
you know i think that
it's very dicey it's a tricky spot uh
for the pga tour but but maybe it's not
maybe what they did a couple of days ago
dan by not allowing their players to
have the releases to go play
in the first live golf event next month
outside of london
maybe that's the power play that the pga
tour uh
thinks is the best move uh to keep its
players uh we've heard the players in
the last couple of days at the att byron
nelson outside of dallas dan say things
like hey if you want to go play you can
play there's nothing stopping the
players dan from going to play in live
golf what they would have to do
is either
lose their pga tour rights in other
words leave the pga tour so now they're
completely independent from the pga tour
but the pga tour is a player
organization dan the players make their
own bylaws if they want to change the
rules if they want to change the bylaws
they can do that
will they do that i don't think they
will the pga tour has been such an
amazing avenue for all of these players
we heard tigers say in december at the
hero world challenge that he has no
interest in live golf
that he is completely backing j monahan
and the pga tour now do they need to
make a couple of tweaks to appease the
star players dan do they need to raise
the the purses or change the way things
are done
especially for the best players in the
world yes they do and the pga tour
recognizes that but
if the players want to go play dan they
can play but it's kind of like freedom
of speech dan you know everybody thinks
freedom of speech covers everything well
it doesn't cover everything and there
are consequences to things that you say
and if you go play live golf and you're
a pga tour member there will be
consequences and yes the pga tour can
suspend the players
great to talk to you as always steve
thanks for joining us
my pleasure dan anytime steve sands nbc
sports play by play also works uh golf
channel